لأول مرة في العالم
روسيا تضرب طائرات البير قدار التركية
والمجنون يزعج جيرانه
مشتهيا رائحة البارود،
ويريد تجريب المزيد من الصواريخ،
فما الذي يريده مجنون كوريا ياسادة؟
حشد عسكري أمريكي وغربي في بولندا،
فهل تزحف الحرب نحوها يا ترى؟ ..
.الدخان يغطي مناطق في كييف
فما الذي يجري؟ وهل تستولي موسكو
على الدعم الغربي الذي يصل أوكرانيا؟ ...
بايدن يحذر من جديد
لكن أذن بوتين صماء تجاه تهديدات واشنطن،
...موسكو تقول بامتلاك أدلة تدين أمريكا،
فما هو موقف مجلس الأمن الدولي؟
.طيور انتحارية  تتجه نحو روسيا
ووزارة الدفاع الروسية تعلن أنها قبضت عليها
هناك أشياء متواصلة فالحصار حول كييف
وغيرها من المدن لا ينقطع والعقوبات الأمريكية
لروسيا تتجدد، ..
وخسائر أوكرانيا تتأكد ومحاولة ضرب
روسيا بسلاحها تعود من جديد..
ألسنة اللهب تتصاعد والدخان الكثيف
يغطي المنطقة في كييف،،
حيث ضربت القوات الروسية مسيرات أوكرانية
من صناعة تركية طراز بيرقدار..
وهكذا فقد أصيب زيلينسكي بخيبة أمل كبيرة
لأن بيرقدار هي أحد أقوى الأسلحة
التي يقاتل بها ضد الروس...
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ أون،
يدعو إلى توسيع موقع  لإطلاق صواريخ بالستية
عابرة للقارات، وتحويله لقاعدة متطورة للغاية،
من أجل أن تصبح قوة فضائية،،
هذا وكانت كوريا الشمالية قد أطلقت صاروخا
قبل أيام وسبقه عدة تجارب أخرى..
١١ دولة منها أمريكا أعربت عن أسفها
لفشل مجلس الأمن الدولي بإدانة هذه التجارب،
ويرى البيت الأبيض أن هذا تصعيد خطير،،
بينما يرفع حزب العمال في كوريا من استعداداته
والتأهب للحرب في حال قامت حرب
ضد حليفتهم روسيا
حشد عسكري أمريكي في أوروبا،،،
هل تمتد الحرب إلى بولندا؟
القلق والتوتر يصيب كل الدول في القارة الأوروبية
لكن الدول المحيطة بروسيا وأوكرانيا
هي الأكثر قلقا، وقد أرسلت أمريكا ٤٧٠٠
جندي أمريكي إلى بولندا،
فيما قررت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
دعم الدول الأوروبية ببطاريات صواريخ باتريوت،،
وفي بولندا أيضا هناك ٤٠٠٠ جندي
من حلف الناتو متواجدون منذ ٢٠١٤
بعد أن ضمت روسيا القرم إليها،
يعلم الرئيس الأوكراني فولوديمير زيلينسكي
أن من يسيطر على السماء سيسيطر على الأرض،
في وقت ترفض فيه الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
دعم أوكرانيا بمقاتلات جوية أو بفرض منطقة
حظر جوي فوق أوكرانيا،،
كل ذلك بينما تزحف قوات موسكو نحو كييف..
زيلينسكي دعا الغرب لاتخاذ قرار سريع
بشأن مقاتلات ميغ٢٩، وكان ذلك بعد
وعود أطلقتها بولندا ولكن عارضتها الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
ورفضت استلام الطائرات من بولندا
لتدعم بها أوكرانيا...
(ميغ٢٩ هي طائرة مقاتلة من الجيل الرابع،
صممها الاتحاد السوفييتي للسيطرة الجوية،
مهمتها تدمير الأهداف الجوية ضمن حدود
تغطية الرادار ، وتدمير الأهداف الأرضية
باستخدام أسلحة غير موجهة،)
وبذلك يحاول الغرب ضرب موسكو بالطائرات
التي صنعتها روسيا..
...
الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن
(أنا لن أتحدث عن معلومات استخباراتية)
وحذر بايدن روسيا من استخدام أسلحة كيماوية
في حربها ضد أوكرانيا وقال أن موسكو
ستدفع ثمن باهظا إن استخدمت أسلحة كيماوية...
وقال أيضا أن بوتين سيفشل في أوكرانيا،
ومع تأكيده كذلك أن أمريكا وحلفاءها
سيسعون لمزيد من العقوبات ضد روسيا
إلا أنه أوضح مرة أخرى أنه لن يخوض
حربا ضد روسيا...
(الأحداث والتطورات)
ضابط روسي يعلن الاستيلاء على
عدد كبير من أنظمة الصواريخ المحمولة
المضادة للطائرات من أنواع مختلفة،
تم الاستيلاء عليها بعد انسحاب قوات كييف
في خريسون...
حصار وقصف روسي مكثف،
وصفارات الإنذار تدوي في  مدن كييف
ولفيف وتشركسي وخاركيف وتشرنيف،
وماريوبول وكذلك في منطقة سومي شمال شرق البلاد ،،
وأعلنت وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية أنها صدت الهجمات
على هذه المدن،،،
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تعلن القبض على طيور
مرقمة تقول إنها أطلقت من مختبرات بيولوجية
أوكرانية نحو منطقتي إيفانوفو وفورونيج في روسيا،
مشيرة إلى أن هذه الطيور تستخدم لنقل أوبئة فتاكة،
وكانت موسكو قد اتهمت واشنطن في مجلس الأمن
بتمويل برنامج بحوث حول أسلحة بيولوجية
في أوكرانيا، وقالت الوزراة الروسية
أن لديها وثائق بشأن إنفاق واشنطن أكثر من
٢٠٠ مليون دولار لتشغيل هذه المختبرات في أوكرانيا..
بصور الأقمار الصناعية روسيا تجهز
لمعركة كبرى..
فالمدرعات تنتشر في المدن
وفي الغابات والمدافع في المواقع الهجومية ..
يقول الباحثون أن روسيا لن تقتحم كييف بعد
إعادة تموضع قواتها ،، ولكن يبدو أن موسكو
تفرض حصارا مطبقا على العاصمة الأوكرانية،
قد يكون حصار استنزاف طويل لقدرات كييف،،
بينما بلغ عدد اللاجئين الأوكران إلى الدول المجاورة
أكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون شخص..
عقوبات أمريكية جديدة على روسيا..
عقوبات على ١٠ أشخاص من مجلس إدارة
مصرف في تي بي (VTB)
وعقوبات على ١٢ عضوا بالدوما
وعقوبات على زوجة وابن وابنة المتحدث
باسم الكرملين ديمتري بيسكوف
وعقوبات تستهدف شخصيات دعمت بوتين
ورجل أعمال مقرب من الكرملين
وعقوبات اقتصادية على شخصين
و٣ كيانات متهمين بدعم برنامج الأسلحة الكوري الشمالي
وزارة الاقتصاد الأوكرانية:
خسائرنا تجاوزت ١١٩ مليار دولار
جراء الحرب الروسية، كما أن أن 75%
من الشركات الواقعة في مناطق القتال توقفت تماما..
زيلينسكي: روسيا تجلب البلطجية والمرتزقة من روسيا
من أجل قتال الشعب الأوكراني
بينما قالت كييف أن متطوعين من ٥٢ دولة
مساهمين في الفيلق الدولي الذي شُكل للقتال
بجانب القوات الأوكرانية..
القوات الروسية تعلن استهداف ٣ منظومات
للصواريخ المضادة للطائرات في أوكرانيا..
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تنشر صورا
لاستهداف قافلة عسكرية أوكرانية
ب ٤ مروحيات قتالية،..
الدفاع الروسية، أعلنت تدمير المركز الرئيسي
لاستخبارات الإشارة الأوكراني في بروفاري
والمطار العسكري في فاسيلكيف،
صور لتواجد آليات عسكرية روسية في محطة
زابوريجيا النووية..
بايدن: سنقيد قدرة روسيا على الاستدانة
من المؤسسات النقدية الدولية
بريطانيا تعلن تزايد عدد الراغبين بالتطوع
للقتال ضد روسيا بعد إعلان وزارة الخارجية
البريطانية دعمها لأوكرانيا
قصف متبادَل بين الجيشين الأوكراني والروسي
في منطقة بروفاري شمال كييف..
موسكو تعيد تموضعها على الأرض الأوكرانية،
فهل يكون ذلك لمراجعة حساباتها
في الهجمات القادمة؟ يبدو أن روسيا تتجه
لحصار بعض المدن الأوكرانية بما في ذلك
العاصمة كييف، عوضا عن اقتحامها،
فكيف سيكون رد الغرب؟،
وماذا سيكون موقف الأوكران من هذا الحصار